hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the 1921
broaches championship match against
Kosovo Capablanca and Emanuele asked her
this is game 11 so far capablanca was
able to win two games last car was
unable to win a single game soccer
Blanca is - two points in the lead and
the last girl has to start doing
something about it or if he just
continues playing the way he played so
far I mean he played excellent chess but
it was not enough to clinch a full point
from the Cuban challenger and he's gonna
have to well differentiate his style a
bit and try to play a bit more risky so
without further ado let's check it out
couple Blanca with the white pieces game
11 he opens with d4 with d5 by Lasker
Knight to f3 and now II six and of
course c4 and the knight to f6 we again
enter the Queens gambit declined Bishop
sorry that's not a Bishop Bishop to g5 9
bt 7 with III the bishop is nicely
developed so you can now close the pawn
chain and the Bishop to e7 with Knight
to c3 Alaska castles and now rook a to C
1 and here rook to e8 we have Queen to
c2 preparing Bishop to d3 to put
pressure on the h7 pawn will see 6 by
Lasker everything pretty standard the
Bishop to d3 and now a trade in the
center D captures on c4 Bishop captures
and now Knight to d5 Alaska offers a
series of trades now Bishop captures on
e7 with rook captures on e7 by Lasker
and now castles by Capablanca and
Knights to f8 from f8 denied we'll do a
good job of defending the h7 square and
now it's Capablanca to move he develops
rook F to b1 and Alaska goes Bishop to
d7 and Congress is that he's not all
that happy about Lasker setup in this
position the rook on e7 Bishop to d7
but alas per has to try something
different if he is to get back into this
match so with E for attacking the knight
and now not Knight captures Queen
captures both
Laxman Capablanca agree that blacks
chances in this position of something
more than a draw are pretty much
non-existent
so Alaska retreats the b6 this comes
with an attack on the bishop and it
gives him time to develop more pieces
we'll push it back to f1 by kappa blanka
and now rook the c8 and here kappa
blanka says it's crucial to prevent c5
so b4 right away taking the c5 squared
from black so c5 is no longer an option
and couple uncle says that he really
enjoys his position now he does have to
worry a little but mainly his plan is to
push if I get the night over to e4 and
then to d6 and then his position will be
just excellent with Bishop today is my
last pair freeing up the Queen's
influence and on the D file and now
Queen to b3 come on who says he can play
a four right away but he doesn't want to
allow Queen to b6 to come with an attack
on the point here so just the first
Queen to b3 now Queen to d6 would be
well a weird way to develop the Queen
because you can just start a for you
prepare a5 and whatever black plays
let's say you try and control the C file
just a5 you push the knight back and now
you push 'if I've you pull the Queen
further back Queen seven now 94 and when
this night lands on d6
it's just positionally lost for black so
after Queen to b3 first rook eat the c7
by Lasker and now a four couple Monken
continues his play on the Queen side now
we have Knight to g6 and the now a5
grabbing more space on the Queen side
Knight to d7 and now II five so finally
freeing de de for square for his night
the night not wants to come to d6 with
be 6 by Lasker and Knights the e4
capablanca just continues with his plan
with rook to b8 hoping to open up at
least one of the files on the Queen side
and now Queen to c3 just getting the
Queen away from the beef up among SS
Queen to a3 would have been better
because after Queen to c3 Alaska is able
to set up our defense with Knight to f4
now the thread is Knight to d5
he's just Rema nuvaring but it will come
with an attack on the Queen so kaboom
anka I said that Queen to a three would
have been better here Knight to d6 as
planned and now Knight to d5 forcing
Capablanca to way
the temple with Queen to a3 with f6 by
black and here cup of Monica says even
though he has a monster night well he
didn't call it a monster night that I'm
calling it that but even though he has a
monster night on b6 and the black
doesn't really have a useful Bishop here
on the 8th it's a crucial to capture on
it because if this Bishop is allowed to
be developed via at the h5e a diagonal
then the bishop will be very stronger
than this diagonal so here we have
Knight captures on e8 it's similar to
the third game Fisher versus Petrosyan
where Fisher just gave up his monster
night for the bishop on d7 that was soon
to be developed which everyone thought
was a crazy idea Queen captures an e 8
and now he captures on f6 and here
capablanca says that capturing with
either of the Knights to preserve the
pawn structure in front of the King
would really weaken the e pawn for
example if you play Knight here captures
then b5 is very strong
you cannot capture the rope here is
undefended and if you try to capture
with the other knife for example this
Knight captures then again you leave the
e5 square for whites night next the b5
is coming and it's gonna be a very nice
position for white so here G captures on
f6 Lasker takes d5 square away from
whites night and now b5 with this move
coupling who says that he's now able to
trade all of the points on the Queen
side and then he now wants to focus on
the game on the King side and in the
center where Lasker has a weak EEP on a
backwards we keep on so we have rook
beat the c8 and now B chapters on c6
rook captures with rook captures on c6
rook captures on c6 a captures on b6 +
88 for some v6 and here okay Lasker has
a past B phone which is very strong but
he also has some weaknesses on the Kings
side and here rook to e1 by Capablanca
going after the weakness that is e 6
cover Blanco later says in his analysis
that maybe Bishop to b5 was stronger but
the engine actually agrees with a couple
Blancas first assessment that rook to e1
is just better if but should be fire
just rooks e7 and black should be ok
here we have Queen to c8
taking control of the C file as the rook
is guarding the e6 pawn and now comes
Knight to d2 capablanca says that this
is the only move to allow white to keep
the initiative for example there should
be five denigrated rook c3 the Queen is
under attack and after the Queen moves
now comes Knight of fate and the east
exponent is nicely protected so here the
game was adjourned capablanca sealed
knife to d2 and when the game was
continued he still thought that this was
definitely the strongest idea on how to
continue the game with Knights to f8 by
Alaska now reinforcing the e pawn and
Knight to e4 now and from here the
knight is the very dangerous piece
putting pressure on a lot of squares and
couple uncle says that maybe you should
play h6 take away the g5 square from
white tonight and then kick it away with
f5 this is one way to go about it but
it's hard to decide when to actually do
this with Queen to d8 by Alaska and now
just h4 we've rook to c7 again couple
bunka things that maybe h6 fall by f5
would have been better but okay rook the
c7 the rope can now also help out with
the defense but also it can be used on
the semi open G file for attacking Queen
to b3 putting pressure here on the e6
pawn also on the b6 pawn with rook to g7
transferring drug into the attack and
also the Queen now end the night now
guard the b6 point with g3 by capablanca
and now route back to a7 as the knight
will now come under attack
Laster is ready to defend it with not
that but would rook the a5 kappa blanka
says that blacks best defensive piece is
the knight on d5 so the way to continue
this game is to remove the knight from D
5 and then the e6 pawn also becomes a
week and that's where you should look
for her chances
so Bishop to c4 and now look the a5
defending the knight on d5 with Knight
to c3 with a triple attack and here
Alaska decides to trade with Knight
captures on c3
Queen captures on c3 and now King to f7
just adding another defender to the e6
pawn and the first part of copper
Blancas plan has been achieved the
knight on d5 is no more with Queen
the III and now comes Queen 2d6
just centralizing the Queen and now
Queen to e4 and here there are all the
threats well the night for example can't
move as you lose this pawn queen the b7
is a threat if you try to prevent Queen
to b7 check would look to a7 d5 is the
idea is Brooke no longer guards the d5
square so after you trade here you would
have a really loose King running around
after King g7 it would just be very very
hard to play this so after this efore
move we've looked a for well Oscar
putting pressure on the bishop here but
now Queen the b7 check and now well the
problem is if you block for example with
Queen t7 then you get Queen to c6 this
just wins the game the rook is under
attack and also there is a triple attack
against the e6 pawn so this is not
possible to do this on the other hand
King to g8 if you go this way then again
Queen to c8 is very strong you just pin
the night and again there's the threat
of capturing an e6 and the bishop is
defended there's really no way around it
if if King to g7 you just unpinned then
still Bishop captures on e6 and now if
Knight captures rook captures will will
lead the mate the Queen has to move
let's say Queen captures on d4 rock e7
King to h6 and now after Queen to a5
there is no defense against rook h7 mate
why black we'll just have to start
giving up pieces but after Queen - b7
last card didn't block Lasker didn't go
king J Glasgow went king to g6 and here
is a very interesting move Capablanca
still played Queen to c8
yeah he still wants to put pressure on
the pawn here and guard the bishop on c4
and it is a it is a good move but there
is a much better move that both
Capablanca and Lasker missed so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this well
elusive idea well I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you were able to do
it congratulations you are an excellent
tactician and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show the idea both of
the mist is h5 check because now
everything wins for white if you capture
the pawn then
you just get Queen f7 check and after
King to g5 Bishop to e2 this is probably
the move both of the missed now there is
no defense against Queen h5 it will be
made as the pawn covers the f4 square
you could try an IG 6 but ninjas Queen
captures on h7 again you're coming to h5
and there's just no way no no good way
of stopping this you could prolong the
game but it will be over very soon
and if after h5 check you don't capture
it if you play King h6 still Queen to f7
just threatening to capture on f6 and
after E 5 that the Queen defense D
captures on e5 f captures on e5 and now
the queen is well on h6 is surrounded by
a lot of pieces of rope c1 can be played
just defending the bishop but also
preparing there should be 5 followed by
rope to c6 and this is just over so
quite a tricky move I mean now that I've
told you about it of course you all
found h5 check but you know as kappa
blanka was really molding the the
position to DES so he would be able to
play Queen to c8 this is what he played
so okay Queen the c8 we have Queen to b4
by Lasker going after the bishop and now
rook the c1 just defending and here it's
very hard to find the move now kappa
blanka is threatening Bishop to d3 check
if you prevent it with let's say queen
a3 then still Bishop d3 check and now
the problem is yes you do win a piece
temporarily but Queen e8 check its check
and well you lose the rock on a4 so
after King g7 you can even start a
mating attack rook c7 checking h6 Queen
captures on f8 check King h5 Queenie
check first to grab the night then you
pick up the rook and of course it's all
over so it's not possible to prevent it
Alaska played Queen back to e7 so couple
one could just play Bishop to d3 check
it is possible to play a 5 this would
prolong the game somewhat but Alaska
went King to h6 we have rook to c7
attacking the Queen Alaska played rook
to e1 check with King to g2 and here
Alaska played Queen to d6 and well feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the winning idea for a cup of lanka
in this
while I give you a couple of seconds
although you probably don't need any
seconds I'm sure you all see it so
congratulations to everyone who found
that you are an excellent player and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy the
show
it's a very nice temporary Queen
sacrifice Queen captures on a fake check
this is what capablanca played and it
was in this position that Emmanuel Oscar
resigned the game and now a cup of
monkeys three points in the lead and it
would be very hard for dr. Lasker to get
back into this match the idea is after
the Queen is captured or you don't
capture the Queen then you just lost the
piece if you capture the Queen then is
just rook captures on h7 and this is
mate the bishop guards the rook and the
pawn guards the g5 square so this is
just checkmate and if you don't capture
the Queen well like I said you're just
down a piece but regardless so for
example King h5 you still get real
characters on h7 check now you will have
to move you can go King g4 and then it's
then it's just over you can do whatever
pretty much here let's say Queen g7 and
this is mate so after this very nice
Queen captures on f8 Alaska resigned the
game and like I said three points in the
lead which is huge if you're playing the
world's championship match and well last
pair will will still try to get back
into the match and we are going to see
what happens after we continue our
couple longer saga so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank young trippa and Parker mining for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous video Sarah
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the couple Blanca
saga checking up on your suggestions and
as we usually do here so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day